normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government let's
jump to this story we got this tweet
from AI not kill everyone ISM memes okay
and they they are uh playing a video
from Sam Altman who says he fears the
impact that AI is going to have on the
election it's not defects he makes a
really great point he says the main
worry I have is not one that gets
airtime on the issue of deep fakes he
says we all you know talking about deep
fakes is fighting the last war we we all
have some degree of immunity to this we
know that when there's a video or photo
or audio we we should check and make
sure it could be fake and then he's
asked well then what do you mean and he
says the thing I'm really worried about
is customized one-on-one persuasion
ability a foreign adversary that has
trained their own AI system that none of
us even know about like systems on the
internet powered by AI that are just
like subtly influencing you the
interviewer says I fear manipulation by
AI ease my concerns I I just want to you
know I bring this up because guys we're
2024 is around the corner we are uh
we're going to be off for the last week
of this month so there's only a couple
weeks left we're going to be doing shows
and talking about this stuff but 2024 is
is is just about here and this is
already happening 100% already starting
in probably 2015 and getting crazier
actually I think it's fair to say with
the Advent of social media this degree
of manipulation has existed and it's
been getting crazier and crazier and as
of right now I'm willing to bet you are
already being manipulated by AI now of
course I know the immediate reaction
from everybody is that's not what AI
means Tim you're talking about
algorithms and it's like okay dude no
we're speaking generally that computers
are automated to the point where they're
manipulating information in a variety of
ways to sell products or to get people
to win elections and I say AI because
it's probably already outside the
control of human beings so so when you
go on Twitter when you go on Facebook
Instagram or whatever you don't realize
this but yeah they are probably you are
probably being influenced by this
machine that has no end goal no real
intention here's the scary thing a human
being has a goal I want this person to
be president for this reason an AI has I
want this person to stare at the screen
for 10 seconds longer and that and they
will it will throw whatever in front of
your face to make that happen now of
course people are going to say that's an
algorithm sure fine if you're talking
about artificial general intelligence
then the real fear is the AGI will make
you serve it as a a demigod master and
you won't even realize that you live for
the machine but you know in the general
sense we are all already being
manipulated for the 2024 election that's
happening now yeah I think you're right
I've stopped not completely but I've
kind of stopped taking negative comments
seriously even remotely if I don't know
who they're from I even tell sometime
it's probably an AI and I know it's not
probably an AI but though it's possibly
an AI and I'm just not going to taint my
mind with that crap you're breaking out
of the Matrix yeah but the positive
comments I still take seriously what if
those are AI they might dead internet
Theory dude you know dead internet
Theory I know uh that what 80% of the
people on the internet are are fake are
fake and you go and you're talking to a
computer dude you're standing in front
of you I got 1.8 million followers
almost 1.9 million followers and so when
I tweet what people think is that there
is a million 2 million people all
standing there like with their phones up
recording when in reality maybe it's a
100,000 who knows they do they have
these apps where you can like check how
many files are organic and whenever I do
it it's like oh they're all real or
whatever I don't buy it I think the
whole thing is fake I tweet something
out I get a bunch of generic random
anime squirrels or whatever and I'm just
like I wonder if F AI that Sam alman's
talking about is like all it's trying to
do is confuse you so whatever you make a
video you make a video about I walked in
the sky was beautiful today you get a
comment of no it was really nasty out or
you say I really like this candidate for
president well that candidate's really
nasty don't you see and then I assume
the AI wants you to continue to interact
with it that's what its ultimate goal is
because it needs your input to have data
continue to make decisions about what to
do next I mean I have a very rudimentary
understanding of AI but that that's what
it seems like it needs it needs human
interaction to continue to basically use
us to figure out what you like to do and
to to entially behavioral model or
whatever and so I what I find
interesting is that we have been letting
ourselves be susceptible to wanting to
interact with the AI for a long time I
mean this is what we talk about with
young teenagers who are essentially
addicted to social media because they
see all their value in the number of
likes the number of engagements how long
their snapstreak is all of these metrics
to say open the open your phone right
now you have a notification you have a
click you want to respond you don't want
to be the one who doesn't respond to the
Snapchat store you have to have
something up actually if your Instagram
page you know if you interact with it
enough it gives you more it's more
likely to show yourself like it's always
driving you back to using it all the
time which is also what the AI wants you
to do the a AI wants to continue to
learn what you're doing so it needs you
to constantly come back to it right and
he mentioned specifically you know
foreign adversaries I think it's
important for us to realize that this
isn't just China like it's our own
government to what extent our you know
agencies like the FBI and the NSA using
AI to influence American citizens when
they go to at the polls in 2024 I mean I
think that needs to be a real concern
cuz you look at an agency like the FBI
who has a long history of entrapping
Americans and pushing them and
incentivizing them to do certain things
I think you know we can't put it past
these guys to be using this to reach
their own ends and private companies for
sure like reading about the business
plot this Smedley Butler plot 1933 these
Bankers tried to get Smedley Butler to
overthrow the US government andall a
fascist dictatorship is SMY Butler was
like the top General on in the United
States they really wanted to overthrow
March 500,000 dudes on Washington this
is like a real plot why did they want to
do it cuz Federal FDR took us off the
gold res the gold standard and they were
like he's going to destroy the economy
we have to take him out of office and
put a put a general in and and become
fascist like melini it was so crazy that
that like and they're just totally
willing like the Federal Reserve in
formation on the The Jackal Island these
guys have like the this the private
sector when we talk about foreign agents
that the private sector are foreign
agents corporations are foreign agents
to our government they're not part of
our government they might exist on in
the United States but they are foreign
agents so they might also very well be
the ones trying to manipulate us well
I'm not sure well I mean we know for a
fact it is the government manipulating
us along with the massive corporations
so you know welcome welcome to the
nightmare welcome to hell baby it's
going to be look we talked about this
last week I post a deep fake of Nancy
Peli a year and a half ago and it looked
hilariously bad and disgusting you post
a deep fake of lanc py now and it's it's
hilarious and realistic where are we
going to be with AI voice uh deep faking
it's going to be perfect so we're we're
going into 2024 deep fakes are bad but
the the real issue is that there's
probably already right now with GPT
being public there are probably millions
of AI chatbot accounts on social media
that are programmed just to respond in
certain ways but slightly unique it used
to be that if you searched for a certain
phrase you'd see like 10,000 accounts
all tweeting the same exact quote and
you knew it was a bot Farm or something
but now they're going to use these these
large language models to generate semi
unique but similar responses they're
going to program into it whenever you
see anything about the with these
subject matter respond with a quote
that's has these parameters and now
someone's going to get bombarded by a
bunch of cartoon squirrels communist
squirrels on Twitter and they're going
to believe it's real life and then
they're going to be like I I need to I
need I need to behave like this because
noral it could be like if music is
played in video put fire Emoji in chat
if user of video says positive things
about concept we want them to talk about
positively if they say negative things
in chat if negative words are used give
thumbs down emoji when music plays like
crazy manul it's crazy than that that's
so rudimentary you're going to get three
you're going to get someone they're
going to you're going to Tweet something
like I think that we need to be back on
the gold standard Ron Paul was right and
the AI will generate a response that is
five five tweets long numbered it's
going to be like Ian you're wrong about
this here's why and you're going to see
a picture of a guy and you're going to
be like well that's probably a real
person and in reality it's just one of
the faceless husks of the of the
narrative machine being programmed just
to convince you that you're wrong and
they interact with each other you'll see
conversations in the comments and those
could all be AI trying to could all be
fake could all be not real it's possible
that we're not even in this room right
now that everyone watching at home is
all all CGI where I'm start to be like
just have have kids and like spend time
with your children cuz that's not going
to get defected out of you like and
maybe maybe people will be tricked into
thinking their family is not their
family or vice versa I want to start
asking regular people that I meet do
they have accounts on on X or Instagram
or Tik Tac or whatever so many people I
know are not on on X like it's it's hard
to be in the media space without being
on it and so I think that we have a
warped perspective I think most people I
know are not on like my just friends
that I have made throughout my life are
not on at all and so there's stuff that
blows up online that we know about we
think oh this happened and that will
influence section but actually like
there's a lot of people who don't know
about this this thing that trended for a
week it's like a separate Universe well
one of the stories that we'll we'll get
into later is Bill Maher saying when
Roseanne says your MK Ultra he goes
who's that he was played so ignorant in
that interview with Roseanne she brought
up CLA Schwab and he was like who's CLA
Schwab really but but no no no this is a
guy who lives on CNN yeah that's Bill
marah's thing it's like he grew up
watching MSNBC and that is what his
worldview is that's it it's so funny
though because leftists and progressives
look to him as an intellectual like how
ironic is that really I feel do the left
hates the coastal Elites though I feel
like some of them those are liberals
yeah leftists think classical liberals
Look to Him class classical Liberals are
rightwing so all the time classical
liberal means crazy riddle well so
classical classical liberal refers to
right-wing like right Libertarians
traditional liberal would refer to like
Democrats from 15 years ago and so
that's bah leftists think he's rightwing
and they call him a fascist and they
call him altright and they've called him
altright for like eight years mhm it's
weird how much the left just dragged
themselves over and said no the
moderates are actually far right they're
crazy don't listen to them like they
have just completely moved the map I
like if you ever see one of those videos
of someone moving a house across a field
like and we all were just like okay
sounds good and now the skew of what's
right and what's far right and what's
left is so off I feel like we need to
just recalibrate it to where most of
America actually is I'm wondering
someone super chated as a joke this
Super Chat isn't real but serious
serious question have you guys in the
chat asked yourselves how many of the
people posting are probably not even
real and how many of the super chats
aren't even real I'm not even J cutting
the value of our show you'll see value
listening to us every once in a while
you'll see a comment in the live chat
and then immediately the same comment
from a different account same like same
capitalization everything it'll just be
two sentences identical and the other
thing too is if there is an influence
operation you might be a regular person
in the regular chat and you're posting
your opinions and you can't compete with
a foreign entity or corporation that is
paying for the super chats to make sure
their views are more prominently
displayed above yours and speaking of
not being able to compete with AI man in
in day trading you know you try and do
day trading with crypto or you can't
compete with the AI it and you might
make a little bit along with it but that
stuff is driving the market the crazy
stuff is like the crypto arbit arrage
where like people make millions of
dollars a year doing literally nothing
just by like making a scent on a trade
yeah I don't I don't I don't know
exactly how it how it works but oh
that's where they'll get it on one
market and then immediately sell it on
another Market where it's slightly sort
of when a when a when a a transfer is
executed the computer can move in and
make a deal faster than the human can so
when a human's making a deal it's going
through the system and the computer just
instantly jumps in between and then gets
a fraction of a penny from that trade
and then you do that Millions upon
millions of times and you are just
shaving off fractions of a scent into
your account so there are people out
there doing this I don't know I I I was
told it's legal I don't know anything
about it but there are people who make
millions of dollars and they do nothing
literally they click go button that's
wild yeah I think I think that happens
with stocks and stuff Arbitrage exists
for like currency so like one currency
will have the worth in one place and
it's worth way less in the other place
and you'll just take the money or worth
way more so you take the money there and
you go sell it over
the exch it's legal so well I mean like
in the real world it makes sense to buy
water in one place and bring it to
another yep like we talked about this
with a lot of disasters when they like
make price gouging illegal and I I I
think price gouging is mostly fine I
mean that's it like there's imagine
there's a disaster and there's no water
so somebody buys a bunch of water and
drives it into the disaster Zone and
sells it for like five bucks a bottle
and people are buying it well I'm pretty
sure those people don't want to D and
they're willing to spend the five bucks
a bottle and that person who loaded up
all that stuff did a lot of work bought
fuel drove into a disaster Zone and
brought relief water why can't they sell
it for what they want if people don't
want to buy it they don't have to buy it
it becomes questionable if there's
limited resources and they got in early
when everyone was going there to get the
water for free to bring to the disaster
site but some one guy got in like just
before and bought it all up he selling
it at a 400% markup what Doan how do how
do you buy water for are you saying like
if they took free relief water and then
tried reselling it it's a different
story well if there was like water at a
store and then there was a disaster and
then one guy went to the store bought
all the water and then like 4 hours
later a bunch of the disaster relief
guys get to the store to get the water
that they're going to bring for free but
it's already bought up it's never going
to be for free or cheap they're going to
deliver it at no cost they they they
they'd buy it and then deliver it yeah
but instead it had been bought up by one
guy and he's going to mark it up 500%
that's I think you could argue that
people that should be illegal why should
that be illegal um because it's a
disaster and it should be treated like
National Emergency Security National
Defense so for a dude to try and profit
off that I think is unethical at the
very least and you could argue that it
should be illegal the question then
becomes where what other areas are you
not allowed to buy a product when you
expect high
demand maybe non- disaster relief I mean
if they're not disaster relief
situations that's a different story
Marley got smacked with for it for his
medicine yeah he raised like a diet what
was it a it was uh I oh man I want to
say it was it has nothing to do with uh
what's the word diabetes I think it was
insulin shots I'm not really diabetes
not totally sure he he like marked it up
700% I don't want to miss yeah I was
like 700% I don't remember it was
exactly I feel like the other challenge
would be you know what if the federal
government decides that your issue is
not a disaster and so price gouging like
allowed there it becomes like sort of
unclear when and if we allow some
protections and not like I'd rather have
a blanket rule either you're allowed to
do it or you're not allowed to you know
what I mean yeah normally the market
it's it's an interesting point to be
made that someone goes to store and buys
all the water right before a disaster
and then after the disaster sells it
because the question is how did he know
how did he know the disaster was coming
it's like Congressman trading like how
many times do they buy defense stocks
and then there's an attack yeah yeah
that's what I'm doing I've been
following this guy that trades
exclusively off of like what Congress
trades on it's doing pretty well not
going to give you Financial advice by
the way not Financial advice but yeah I
think I think people are saying like the
Pelosi tracker was like 20% or something
it's crazy it probably came from back in
the day when like a disaster would hit
and then one guy would run to the store
and get all the water and then he'd come
back and be like hey everyone I brought
all the water but it's going to be five
times more the crowd would be like we're
not going to put up with that that was
back before like when Common Sense kind
of Ruled The Roost before like he's like
I have a contract there there's still a
problem here the problem is in this
scenario how is it that he got to the
store and bought the water with with no
one else realizing they needed water or
he just had the fastest car or okay so
potentially this guy just saw there is a
disaster coming there is starting to be
water whatever I'm going to do this
rather than prepare my own house this is
the thing I think is worth spending my
time to do and he made an investment he
decided that this was the thing he
should do buy the water instead of maybe
like leave the city or like locked down
his house or whatever disaster he's in
I'm really not sure the problem with the
argument there is that let's say
somebody has a well on their property
and they make water and then all of a
sudden demand for water is skyrocketing
everybody wants the water from his
property so he's like okay to maintain
this and deliver this much water I'm
going to charge more money and this is
my opportunity this is why I invested in
this and you say no it's a disaster
people need water you can't do that okay
list now now we'll go to Food well now
you got a guy who grows lots of food and
then demands spikes as food shortages
hit and they say no you can't you can't
sell your food for for a higher price
because we're in a shortage so we just
we're going to buy your food at at Mark
at at at a at a government locked rate
and then if you say that's acceptable
you get into all the other areas well
people need clothes people need shoes
people need fuel and then you start
price locking everything I kind of I I
understand what you're saying about
someone going to a gas station or
whatever and buying it up but the
problem is still if a disaster hits no
one has any advanced forn knowledge of
the disaster perhaps it's the problem of
the gas station of the store deciding to
sell all of their stock to one guy and
you know and and they say we don't care
you can buy it all yeah you can also
redefine what a disaster is and that can
be used against people be like hey it's
a disaster you have to give your I mean
food rationing things like that yeah the
government then says uh uh well you know
the economic downturn qualifies as a
disaster so we're taking your water
we're taking all these products from
your store and we're going to give them
that for free that's what worries me
because when the government decides to
disaster these things these rules would
suddenly apply but again it's not
consistent there are sometimes
communities that need help and the
federal government will be like no
you're not serious enough and other
times they're like no we have to
intervene here I mean wasn't this
something we talked about with um East
Palestine like the fact that the the
chemical spill was a big deal and the
federal government kind of ignored it
I'm not saying we should have gone to
price gouging but it is interesting that
we would ultimately be deciding this is
something the federal government should
elect tell us and I don't like that
there was some story where a guy fil
filled up his pickup truck with a bunch
of bottles of water drove into a
disaster area and sold them for like
five bucks each and he got in trouble
they were like how dare you and my
attitude is kind of like would you
rather have $5 water or no
water was obvious $5 water otherwise
you'll just die you know but they were
like yeah but he's exploiting a crisis
okay then just tell him not to bring the
water next say okay I won't bring you
any water and then you all dive
dehydration in New York you'll see like
umbrella salesmen and there'll be a buck
and no one over then when it rains
they're like $9 each that's right boom
hey fa it was going to rain that's
that's exploitation but this is true
you'll guys will be standing outside
their little carts or whatever and The
Umbrellas will be well yeah they'll be
like five bucks and they'll be in a
little bin as soon as the rain comes you
see a different sign flop down it's 15
bucks and they sell them like hot cakes
yep since they're non-essential I
understand I like that actually I really
like Tak advantage ofu and then let's
let's you know what fine I'm sick of I'm
sick of Walmart jacking up the price of
winter coats as soon as it gets cold out
have you noticed this if you buy if
you're buying winter clothing in summer
it's cheap but now it's cold and people
are freezing to death and they're trying
to exploit us no it's fine this this is
the point of supply and demand you
charge more when the opportunity arises
yeah price gouging and price limiting
are both kind of federally well you
don't want the government to to limit
the prices company can set because then
the company goes out of out of business
and that destroys the economy but then
how do you stop companies from price
gouging what's the rules and the laws on
that thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net